Republicans have a big victory in
Montana one day after their candidate
was charged with assault for body
slamming a reporter Greg Jim Forte one
Thursday special election to fill
Montana's only congressional seat he
received around 50% of the vote Gian
Forte celebrated with his supporters
overnight he also apologized for
Wednesday's confrontation and this is
the second time Democrats have lost a
special house election seen as a
referendum on President Trump Mary
Peterson is in Bozeman Montana very good
morning good morning well the Bozeman
Daily Chronicle says it all GN for T
Trump's Crist Chris being the Democratic
opponent he also apologized for
assaulting that reporter so in victory
he seemed both happy and humble I should
not have responded in the way that I did
and for that I'm sorry and you're
forgiven a victorious Greg Jim 40
apologized directly to the reporter who
accused GM 40 of body-slamming him I
should not have treated that reporter
that way and for that I'm sorry
mr. Ben Jacobs on Wednesday The Guardian
newspaper released an audio recording of
the confrontation after Jacobs asked GM
for T his stance on the house health
care legislation GM 40 was later charged
with misdemeanor assault Shane please
tired you got the last time you came
here you did the same thing get the hell
I get the hell out the last time do that
same to you the Guardian yes if you just
broke my losses
you last guy to do the same damn thing
you just body find me it broke my
glasses that's not the person that I am
and it's not the way I'll lead in this
state House Speaker Paul Ryan was among
the Republicans urging Jim 40 to
apologize should the gentleman apologize
yeah I think he should apologize
Republicans poured millions into this
race President Trump even put out a robo
call he's a wonderful guy he knows how
to win he's going to win for you Jim for
T's supporters appeared to take his
apart
gee at face value you think this puts it
behind him I honestly do I think you
know this is this is part of life
Republican leaders say gee and 40s
victory is a vindication for the White
House do you see this as a vote not just
for the Montana but for the president
yes I do
why because they want his policies to
succeed June 40 must appear in court
before June 7th on these charges he
faces a $500 fine or six months in jail
or both Representative Paul Ryan said
this morning that elections are about
choices in as the speaker said Montanans
made their choice Alex Barry thanks